[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
soixante dix huit pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale nous sommes le
mercredi 4 décembre voici les titres
grande partie de cette édition consacrée
à la journée de grève
interprofessionnelle ce jeudi 5 décembre
plusieurs millions de salariés du public
et privé sont appelés à se mobiliser
contre la future réforme des retraites
sur ce plateau trois syndicats qui
travaillent à la construction d'un plan
d'action contre le projet doit les
prévisions également des perturbations à
prévoir demain dans les yvelines et des
eaux usées transformé en gaz vert pour
l'utilisation des particuliers sur le
principe de l' usine de biométhanisation
qui vient d'être inauguré aux mureaux
c'est la première unité de ce type en
ile-de-france enfin pour lutter contre
le gaspillage les écoliers et des
coudrais à maurepas des jeunes avec un
invité particulier un robot qui contrôle
la quantité d aliments jetés par les
enfants et puis à suivre dans ce journal
également le programme des films à
l'affiché au cinéma le grenier à sel
attrape une journée noire en prévision
demain dans les yvelines facteurs en
enseignant professionnel de santé avocat
cheminots électriciens et gaziers
d'autres professions dans la rue est les
syndicats ont lancé un appel à une
mobilisation massive contre le projet de
loi de réforme des retraites voulu par
le gouvernement pour m'accompagner dans
cette première partie d'édition or il
est heureusement soir et de la rédaction
tv 78 dans un instant vous nous direz
quel sont les perturbations à prévoir
pour la journée de demain dans le
département trois invités aussi autour
de la table trois syndicats trois
représentants de syndicats dans les
yvelines sonia porot bonsoir danse avec
la secrétaire départementale de la cgt
soixante dix huit dominique ruffier
bonsoir soit secrétaire départemental de
force ouvrière 78 enfin bertrand mesure
bonsoir vous êtes représentant de fsu
dans les yvelines donc syndicats
d'enseignants
et vous êtes également co secrétaire du
snuipp ep 1 dans les yvelines qui est
son pour les enseignants du premier
degré alors pour cette grève vos trois
syndicats partiront unis également avec
solidaires 78 l'unité syndicale face à
un tel projet de loi vous ne pouviez pas
faire son ce niveau mais je pense que ça
va ça montre quand il ya une unité comme
ça qu'ils qui a inclus d'ailleurs
d'autres organisations syndicales cfe
cgc s'est joint la cftc voilà les ces
syndicats libres de mobiliser ça ça
montre effectivement l'ampleur de
l'opposition à un tel projet de réforme
mais dans les yvelines une mobilisation
je le dis aussi avec solidaires 78 vous
étiez d'ailleurs mobilisé le 21 novembre
dernier en gare de saint quentin en
yvelines et de mantes-la-jolie tout à
fait noir pour distribuer on n'a jamais
d'ailleurs distribué autant depuis pas
mal pas mal d'années je crois et c'est
un sujet de façon les retraites qui
concerne tout le monde et à ce titre là
tous les syndicats se sentent concernés
demain c'est une grande mobilisation qui
est prévue à paris avec un défilé
quelle est l'organisation pour amener
tous les militants vers la capitale en
fait la seule solution qui reste c'est
l'écart et le covoiturage puisque les
transports en commun seront profondément
affecté donc nous avons mobilisé les uns
et les autres
plusieurs cars c'est qu'il y en a quatre
pour la fsu je sais qu'il a beaucoup
pour la cgt 8 ports est faux et ça va
être là les moyens d'emmener les
personnes qui veulent manifester à paris
il y aura une manifestation à paris mais
aussi des actions locales prévu c'est ça
oui il ya un certain nombre de syndicats
qui vont faire des piquets de grève des
assemblées générales pour discuter
notamment de comment on continue ce
mouvement là des rassemblements devant
des collectivités ou des entreprises
donc une mobilisation et qui s'annonce
vraiment exceptionnel on parle dans un
instant de ce qui vous oppose à cette
réflexion autour des retraites est aussi
parlé du travail commun que vous menez
actuellement dans les yvelines
et ce plan d'action et qui est en
préparation contre la future loi or il
est onze d'abord journée noire en
prévision je le disais tout à l'heure
dans les yvelines parmi les secteurs les
plus touchés
demain ce sont les transports il sera
compliqué de se déplacer dans le
département oui tout à fait notamment
avec les transilien
par exemple si vous avez l'habitude de
prendre la ligne e et bien sachez
qu'aucun train ne circulera entre la
défense et la verrière pour la ligne n
est bien comme vous pouvez le voir
également
aucun train ne circulera dans les
yvelines que ce soit entre rambouillet
saint quentin en yvelines ou encore
entre plaisir grignon et versailles
chantiers il aura sur cette ligne n
ligne n pardon seulement quelques trains
en heure de pointe le matin et en fin de
journée ce sera sur la ligne entre paris
montparnasse et saint quentin en
yvelines voilà comme vous le voyez elle
s'affichait sur votre écran
concernant maintenant les lignes de rer
comptez 1 train sur 2 en heures de
pointe sur le rer a en train sur trois
sur le rer b
aucun train sur le rer c entre paris
austerlitz et saint quentin en yvelines
et puis la ligne 6 également du tramway
qui dessert notamment
vélizy-villacoublay serein pathé puisque
un tram sur 2 circulera toute la journée
ça c'est pour le réseau des ferroviaire
et réseau tramway aussi et skull le
réseau des bus sera perturbé également
alors sur le réseau stibus les lignes
desservant les établissements scolaires
seront assurés en priorité pour en
savoir plus sur votre ligne est bien
n'hésitez pas à vous connecter sur le
site www.sgbourse.fr concernant par
contre les réseaux hourtoule et phébus
et bien pas de perturbations annoncées
pour demain à certaines sont même
renforcées
autre secteur touché celui de
l'éducation de nombreux établissements
scolaires seront fermés demain
en effet le mouvement s'annonce très
suivie chez des enseignants selon
d'ailleurs le site de l'académie de
versailles près de 300 écoles
maternelles et primaires dans les
yvelines sont susceptibles d'être
fermées alors une question comment les
parents vont s'organiser et bien mélanie
poké et mathilde de mini sont allés vous
poser la question un petit mot dans le
dans leur cahier donc du coup on marie a
pris sa journée
moi j'ai posé des congés du combat les
enfants qui restent avec moi
personnellement j'ai la chance en ce
moment d'être en recherche d'emploi donc
c'est une période de transition donc je
suis disponible
mais voilà j'ai proposé à plusieurs
parents qui peuvent pas faire autrement
j'ai proposé de du coup de récupérer
leurs enfants
j'ai fait du télétravail voilà donc je
me suis organisé avec mon chef et je
vais bosser de la maison comme je suis
la mamie la solution elle est toute
trouvée
voilà donc mon fils et ma belle fille
ils vont travailler comme ils peuvent et
moi je vais garder les petits
alors si les parents ne peuvent pas
s'organiser bien sachez que la loi
d'août 2008 instaure le service minimum
d'accueil quand le nombre de grévistes
dépasse les 25% c'est à la commune
d'assurer l'accueil
cependant attention dans certaines
communes dans certains établissements
bien la cantine ne sera pas assuré pour
plus d'information bien sûr n'hésitez
pas à vous rendre sur le site internet
de votre commune et quelles sont les
solutions pour les salariés qui auraient
des difficultés à se rendre sur leur
lieu de travail alors de nombreuses
entreprises proposent dans la mesure du
possible de faire du télétravail ce jour
là c'est le cas également par exemple du
conseil départemental des yvelines et il
existe également plusieurs espaces de
coworking
et puis autre solution est bien le
covoiturage d'autant plus qu'il sera
gratuit pour tous les passagers pendant
les jours de grève c'est ce qu'a annoncé
la région ile de france
pour cela il suffit de se connecter sur
le site où l'application et via un avis
go et si vous êtes conducteur est bien
votre trajet pourra être remboursé
jusqu'à 4 euros si vous êtes inscrit sur
l'une à des cinq plateformes partenaires
et qui s'affiche sur votre écran blabla
lines à carros ou encore claque site
merci aurélie pour ces précisions pour
compléter vos propos j'ajoute qu'une
journée noire s'annonce aussi dans dans
les universités pour les quelques 20
mille étudiants notamment de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines une manifestation étudiante est
prévue demain en gare de versailles
chantiers les autres auront sans doute
du mal à se rendre sur les différents
campus de l'établissement du vécu qui a
demandé à ses enseignants est de faire
preuve de souplesse
avec les retardataires et les absents la
journée de demain ne sera pas pour
autant banaliser déjà sur ce qui vient
d'être dit sur la grève qui va être qui
va être suivi dans les différents
secteurs dans les différents corps
professionnel les enseignants d'abord
est ce que beaucoup d'enseignants ont
prévu de faire grève alors il y avait le
taux de 83 % qui il ya une au pointage
était sorti en début de semaine qui est
toujours un peu délicat puisque depuis
qu' un service minimum d'accueil les
enseignants se déclarent une intention
de faire grève et puis après il reste à
voir comment il se réalise nous on
estime qu'il ya en eu environ entre 70
et 75 % des enseignants qui vont faire
grève
effectivement je pense qu'il y aura
beaucoup plus que le nombre d'écoles que
vous avez annoncé qu'ils seront fermés
j'ajouterai que le service minimum
d'accueil sera aussi impactés par le
fait que ces grèves
interprofessionnelles et que donc les
personnels communaux n'assureront pas
non plus leurs services du côté de fo et
de la cgt sera nommé membre nous
confirme parce qu'on n'a jamais vu
autant de personnes téléphonaient que ce
soit enseignant rhône et y compris
encore aujourd'hui pour demain pour
réserver des places dans les cas là
c'est pareil c'est la première fois
qu'on voit ça depuis très longtemps
oui je confirme clairement nous on aura
des gens qui qui n'auront pas de place
dans les bus et pourtant il y en a plus
d'une trentaine et c c'est un chiffre
c'est assez historique et on voit
vraiment des professions très diverses
se mobilisent et voilà par exemple dans
l'aide à domicile
il y aura des débrayages également donc
c'est vraiment l'ensemble des salariés
qui se sentent concernés qui ont des
revendications exprimées
d'ailleurs si on rentre dans le fond de
ce projet de réforme des retraites il
s'appuie sur les préconisations du
haut-commissaire au retrait jean paul
delevoye et des mesures déjà annoncées
fondre les quarante deux régimes
spéciaux en un régime unique et
universel
le calcul des droits par points lâche
d'équilibré fixé à 64 ans apprend qu'il
n'est pas encore totalement tranché un
qui fait débat notamment
on l'a vu lors des différentes
concertation citoyenne organisée en
novembre à vélizy villacoublay
ça c'était donc ans le 18 novembre et où
chine et rocquencourt la semaine
dernière écouter justement à ce propos
le haut-commissaire aux retraites
interrogé à par nicolas landry
dès le départ j'ai souhaité faire appel
à l'intelligence citoyenne
ce projet qui est un projet de société
concerne tout le monde
les enfants les petits enfants les
parents les retraités et donc l'on voit
bien qu'il est important pour moi d'être
au contact des citoyens pour voir ce qui
dans le projet suscite leur adhésion
leurs inquiétudes et à laquelle je dois
répondre et il est important aussi de
faire de la pédagogie nous sommes dans
des démocraties qui sont souvent guidés
par des pulsions émotionnel or ce qu'il
m'apparaît devoir être une
responsabilité du politique c'est
d'offrir à chacun le moyen de se faire
une conviction même si elle est
contraire à la vôtre déjà on va vous
demander pourquoi il ya une mobilisation
demain une réaction sur ce que l'on
vient d'entendre cette ode de
concertation ce que ce n'était pas un
passé par le gouvernement le fait de
donner la parole aux citoyens lors de
différentes concertations écouter une
concertation c'est toujours utile sauf
que je pense que ce qui caractérise
cette réforme c'est que ni le partage
des richesses ni lait ni la décision ne
sont partagés c'est à dire que on nous
présente quelque chose dont tout le
monde a fait le constat que ce sera une
baisse des retraites pour l'ensemble des
personnes ceux qui sont actuellement la
retraite mais ceux qui sont bientôt à la
retraite
et ça ça n'est pas négociable puisque la
part de la richesse nationale qui est
consacrée aux retraites
dans un contexte où le nombre de
retraités augmente et est fixé à 14 % et
ne sera jamais augmenté en cinq portes
de concertation qui s'achèvera le 9 et
10 décembre avec la remise des
conclusions de jean paul delevoye la
présentation de la loi on va voir le
calendrier s'afficher sera prévu pour
2020 l'été 2020 entrée en vigueur en
2025 même si edouard philippe le premier
ministre s'est dit ouvert à un report
ans en 2030
du coup le projet de loi n'est pas
encore totalement établie pourquoi il
faut ce pour quoi vous vous mobilisez du
coup de main avant même que fit le
projet de loi final soit soirée 10 est
d'abord parce qu'il ya des grandes
lignes dont on sait qu'elles sont
néfastes au niveau au niveau des
pensions le régime universel les les
points et puis bien sûr qu'on peut
aujourd'hui améliorer le système de
retraite en restant par répartition un
système solidaire comme on a
actuellement et la question
effectivement de la répartition des
richesses créées par le travail elle est
vraiment posée 6
éliminait les inégalités salariales
entre les hommes et les femmes ou à vrai
dire aussi toutes les inégalités de
salaires liées aux discriminations
raciales ou liées au handicap par
exemple d'abord les gens auraient des
salaires plus élevés et il ya besoin de
les augmenter
et puis ça ferait des cotisations
supplémentaires pour le système de
retraites mais évidemment pour ça il
faut que les entreprises acceptent vain
d'avoir un peu moins de bénéfices de
dividendes versés aux actionnaires et
c'est pas à leurs intérêts c'est assez
pour ça qu'il ya ce projet de réforme
des choses à changer quand même donc ce
serait bien sûr puisque les retraités
sont mobilisés de manière unitaire est
également depuis deux ou trois ans pour
le niveau de leurs pensions donc oui il
ya des choses à améliorer mais
certainement pas le système de retraite
par points puis il faut appeler un chat
un chat
le système par points en réalité c'est
un système par capitalisation
au lieu de capitaliser directement d
euros aux capitalistes des points qui
seront transformés en euros donc on est
en train de nous introduire comme ça un
système par capitalisation là on avait
un système par répartition c'est un peut
pas on pourrait accepter si tout à fait
contraire justement la justice qu'on
voulait nous nous un fusée en fait
prétendre à fuser je précise qu'il ya
encore des points qui restent à trancher
quel première génération sera concerné
les mesures d'accompagnement aussi des
fonctionnaires alors il ya une mesure
sur laquelle visiblement le gouvernement
ne reviendra pas c'est la fusion on
parlait un des quarante deux régimes
spéciaux en un seul universel je vous
propose d'écouter un nouveau jean paul
delevoye
quand on est dans l'universalité des
droits c'est les mêmes règles pour tous
un métier identique retraite identique
et tout ce qui ne justifie pas une
spécificité une particularité comme les
artisans les commerçants les professions
libérales ou les professions régaliennes
qui est sûre notre check up étaient tous
là intégrera le régime universel avec un
temps adapte aussi d'adaptation et
d'évolution et de transition et quels
sont justement les risques sur la fusion
de ses 42 régime en un seul parce que
10 régime universel c'est supposer que
la situation des gens et est universel
et que chacun or on sait bien que les
aléas de la vie professionnelle ne sont
pas les mêmes que la répartition du
travail entre les hommes et les femmes
n'est pas du tout la même que les
salaires des uns et des autres ne sont
pas équivalents et dire un régime in her
salle ça veut simplement dire favoriser
ceux qui ont des carrières linéaires qui
sont du bon côté de la barrière qui
n'ont pas d'accident de parcours ou qui
n'ont pas des carrières si je prends
l'exemple qui me concerne comme les
enseignants où on démarre avec un
salaire qui est très en deçà de la
moyenne des pays de l'osce et des oeufs
donc ça veut dire quoi un régime
universel ça veut dire que ce qui rompt
des petites retraites permettront
d'assurer les retraites de ceux qui en
auront des grosses je rappelle
simplement que actuellement un cadre vie
13 ans de plus à la retraite qu'un
ouvrier et donc ça veut dire que c'est
la retraite de l'ouvrier les sacrifices
des ouvriers qui financeront la retraite
des cannes alors pour faire face
justement à ce projet de réforme vous
êtes engagé à construire un plan
d'action c'est ça un plan d'action entre
les différents syndicats contre cette
réforme des retraites
ce projet doit le plan d'action il est
simple à partir du moment nous a pas
entendus
c'est à dire que le gouvernement dès le
départ a dit je ferai ça il a fait
semblant de concerter il a reçu un petit
peu tout le monde mais c'était plus de
la com qu'autre chose c'est sans écouter
ont validé ce pas la concertation
concertation et coûte au moins là ce
n'était pas le cas
voyons maintenant on en arrive il n'y a
plus qu'un seul moyen c'est la grève et
pour nous en tout cas force ouvrière si
la grève reconductible
parce qu'une journée de grève comme ça
on sait très bien que ça ne fera pas
grand chose les volants ses lettres sur
la dernière question c'est vous attendez
une mobilisation longue il ya cette
grande journée demain ça va lancer un
cycle de mobilisations
c'est effectivement réellement
l'objectif que
les salariés continuent à discuter à
mettre en avant aussi leurs
revendications locales et et bien sûr
toutes les revendications nationales qui
sont nombreuses et qui est vraiment une
dynamique de lutte et qu'effectivement
il ya de plus en plus d'entreprises
d'administrations mobilisé que ça
continue page en fonction des
possibilités de chacun voilà des noms
c'est que des petits des petits salaires
des mères isolées peut-être qu'elles
feront qu'une heure de débrayage mais ça
participe à une une mobilisation qui est
qui est importante pour conserver et
améliorer
voilà un système solidaire qui a été
gagnée de haute lutte
puis donc vivront une journée de
mobilisation prévue demain merci à vous
trois sonia porot pour la cgt 78
dominique ruffier pour force ouvrière 78
et bertrand mesure pour fsu yvelines
merci à vous trois dans le reste de
l'actualité locale du gaz vers produit à
partir d'eaux usées est injectée dans le
réseau de distribution le principe de
l'unité biométhane de la station
d'épuration des mureaux exploité par
suez cette unité est une première en
ile-de-france le reportage de manon
varaldo c'est officiel la station
d'épuration des mureaux et la première
d'ile-de-france a transformé ses eaux
usées en gaz vers casque et veste
obligatoire place à la visite dans cette
station d'épuration l'énergie présente
dans les eaux usées va être valorisés à
travers l'installation qui se trouve
juste derrière moi qui ai un méthaniseur
ce méthaniseur va convertir les boues en
énergie en biogaz puis en biométhane qui
vont être injectés au réseau de manière
à satisfaire les besoins de consommation
courante en énergie des citoyens
lusine renforce l'efficacité énergétique
par l'installation d'échangeurs
thermiques et d'une pompe à chaleur
elle traite les eaux usées de 24
communes environnantes et minimise son
impact sur l'environnement en évitant
mille tonnes de co2 par an les 70 mètres
cubes
bouh vont être transformés en biogaz qui
va être épurées biométhane injection
réseau et qui va pouvoir alimenter
l'équivalent de 800 logements donc c'est
un avantage incroyable c'est
l'incarnation de l'économie circulaire
cette unité améliore aussi la qualité
des eaux rejetées dans la seine pour
mieux préserver la biodiversité fin 2019
en ile de france
quinze sites d'injection de biométhane
seront répertoriés dans les réseaux des
collectivités locales ce traitement des
eaux usées ne coûtera pas plus cher aux
habitants de calcul sur la facture c'est
une calcul sur le prix d'entrée de l'eau
et sur le prix de l'eau usée
si nous produisons de l'énergie avec ce
que qu'amène les habitants j'espère
qu'on arrivera à baisser le prix de
l'eau usée
l'objectif est aussi de devenir la
première région de méthanisation
agricole d'ici 2030 des moyens vont être
mis en place dans le cadre du budget que
nous allons voter dans dix jours à la
région vont connaître une augmentation
en faveur de l'énergie de 67%
c'est à dire une augmentation jusqu'à
maintenant jamais réalisé depuis des
années pour soutenir cette transition
énergétique
le coût total de cet investissement à la
station d'épuration des mureaux et de
plus de 40 millions d'euros chaque année
la restauration collective serre en
france plus de 3 milliards de repas 44
kg en moyenne serait jeté par jour par
les établissements un chiffre que de
nombreuses communes souhaite réduire est
depuis le mois de septembre les élèves
de l'école des coudrais à maurepas des
jeunes avec un invité un peu particulier
arthur c'est le nom de ce robot qui
contrôle est la quantité d aliments
jetés par les écoliers mélanie pocket
des yeux en forme d'écrou une lumière
sur la tête et un ventre balance voici
arthur le robot vérifie chaque midi ce
que j'aime les enfants de l'école
élémentaire des coudrais à maurepas
si ça faisait
de 600 grammes et bages pouvait appuyer
sur un bouton pour new york que c'était
le bon choix c'est que j'ai pas trop
gastier sénat du tueur et du coup il
faut pas gâcher pour rien parce qu'il ya
des personnes qui n'ont pas mangé
c'est important parce qu'il y en a qui
ont pas la chance comme un rejet par
tous comme ça installé il ya trois mois
le robot a été pensé par les agents de
la commune il est une nouvelle étape du
programme de lutte contre le gaspillage
alimentaires dans les cantines scolaires
initié il ya un nom avec le principe
petites faims grande forme en font
calibre ses besoins calibre s'il a
vraiment faim si la ilaha illa moins
faim voire parfois s'ils aiment pas et
du coup final quand il a terminé de
manger il jette évidemment - délai ce
ppp des six ans ils peuvent comprendre
que je t'ai c'est pas bien et que ça
peut faire perdre des choses à d'autres
personnes qui sont dans le besoin
le robot est calibré en fonction du menu
prévus chaque jour l'école continue
cette sensibilisation aux gaspillages et
réduire nos déchets le thème du nouveau
numéro du 7 8 sociétés ce soir sur tv
60,18 manouvre à doha cinq invités
autour de la table pour évoquer ce sujet
elle nous vous en parlions dans ce
journal il a été lancé la semaine
dernière le bus santé des femmes a fait
son premier passage lundi dans les
yvelines à un arrêt sur le parking du
centre commercial bel air à rambouillet
l'objectif que les femmes trouvent
gratuitement sur place une aide santé ou
juridique
marylène iapichino le bus santé pour
femmes a effectué son premier passage
dans le département à rambouillet issu
d'un partenariat entre les hauts de
seine et les yvelines il propose un
accès à des services de dépistage et de
conseil entièrement gratuit l'objectif
c'est vraiment de pouvoir toucher des
femmes qui ne vont pas se présenter
spontanément vers les dispositifs
existants et là on est dans un
environnement anonyme confidentiel ne
connaissent pas les professionnels qui
se trouve dans le bus et elles vont
davantage s'est penchée une première
partie santé met à disposition à charge
et de prévention un médecin et une
psychologue
les femmes peuvent tester leur vue leurs
auditions
vérifier leur taux de diabète et de
cholestérol et surtout se confier si l
on ressente le besoin
l'idée c'est de l'art propose un
dépistage conditions visuelles
mais derrière tout ça on est aussi là
pour essayer de d'échanger avec sow la
prévention santé de façon générale c'est
bien parce que
il ya des personnes qui ne se font pas
consulté équipes auraient pu bénéficier
à voir les solutions apportées à leurs
problèmes pas de consultation mais bien
de la prévention l'objectif est ensuite
de les diriger vers les professionnels
du secteur géographique plus que leur
santé un autre volet conseils et écoute
de vie leur est proposé avec un officier
de prévention ou en avocat ça me semble
important actuellement d'informer les
femmes de qu'elles connaissent leurs
droits quelle qu'elles puissent poser
des mots sur des situations qu'elles
vivent chaque jour et qu'on puisse les
aider à cheminer et éventuellement à
judiciariser une situation si si
l'infraction est commise quelle chanson
petit je vais une psychologue et j'ai vu
aussi l'aide sociale aussi donc ça m'a
aidé et m'a donné des informations d
après cela on a c'est très important
comment ce premier but en france rempli
ses objectifs d'information et de
rupture de l'isolément des femmes
il sillonne les deux départements lors
de ses premiers arrêts une cinquantaine
de femmes a pu le visiter chaque jour
noël c'est dans trois semaines à mais
les animations ont déjà débuté des
décorations qui illumina des villes et
des marchés qui se succèdent à montigny
le bretonneux et à saint cyr l'école il
était organisé le week-end dernier
retour avec mélanie poker le père noël a
lancé sa tournée pas encore celle des
cadeaux mais celle des marchés dans son
parcours le marché des voisins
solidaires à saint cyr l'école organisée
par une quinzaine de voisins du quartier
chars le renard on a joué bas la
solidarité des gens c est ce que vous
pouvez nous donner un petit coup de main
une heure de votre temps juste quelque
chose pour que l'on puisse avoir tout
est toutes les générations autour de
nous les commerçants ont joué le jeu
aussi voilà solidaire charcuterie quand
ce champagne et des cadeaux une centaine
d'artisans et commerçants a répondu à
l'appel comme ceux passionnés qui
travaillent le bois de récup
ce qui m'intéresse réellement c'est
partager ma passion encore une fois
c'est partir du jardin est amenée sur la
table et de faire découvrir aux gens que
les arbres qu'on trouve dans le jardin
sommes dans nos forêts une fois qu'on
les ouvre
ils ont plein de couleurs plate forme et
plein de patterns
à montigny le bretonneux la ferme du
manet s'est transformée en eau géantes
pour accueillir les 17 mille visiteurs
plus de 130 exposants s'étaient donné
rendez-vous pour proposer doudou bijoux
et autres douceurs
c'est le foie gras de noël foie gras du
premier de l'or le programme de la fête
de la joie du bonheur
le foie gras du gers pour nous c'est un
rendez vous incontournable
et c'est parce qu'ils mettent en avant
les producteurs de 2,20 de foie gras de
saucisson
et c'est dans ces le marché des
producteurs encore trois semaines pour
que le père noël puisse compléter les
demandes qui lui sont adressées les
marchés donne des idées pour que le 24
décembre soit sur son 31 d'autres
marchés de noël se déroule bien sûr en
ce mois de décembre à saint quentin en
yvelines le prochain à plaisir les
samedi 7 et dimanche 8 décembre au
château de la ville des artisans venus
des quatre coins de la france avec
plusieurs animations promenades en
calèche sculpture sur ballons de
patinoire et ferme pédagogique
le tout en présence du père noël rendez
vous de 9h à 19h voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile vous retrouvez
le replay de cette édition est aussi le
programme à des films à la fiche du
cinéma le grenier à sel à trappes dont
je vous parlais au début de ce journal
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]